also Tuesday Trump started a campaign
against birthright citizenship and
joining us today to discuss the
implications is host of his own TV and
radio show please welcome David Pakman
to Muller she wrote David thanks for
joining us thanks so much for having me
so I've seen you tweeting a little bit
and I know you're working I think you
said you were working on a story about
wanting people's opinions about what's
going on with the attack on birthright
citizenship
yeah I think there's a few interesting
elements to this I mean the first one is
like with any of these stories that sort
of seems to pop out and then take over
the media discussion for 24-48 however
many hours I always am interested in
thinking about is is the story
distracting from other important stories
and that doesn't mean that these are
planted distractions but just sort of
that they become de facto distractions
sometimes from something may be more
pressing like for example the midterm
elections but the other interesting
story for me about the birthright
citizenship idea which is using an
executive order to end something that at
least appears to be according to legal
experts codified by the Fourteenth
Amendment is not so much is it legally
possible because that that's that's sort
of one aspect to it but if you don't
have birthright citizenship how do you
determine who gets to be a citizen and
it might seem really obvious because
those who favor getting rid of
birthright citizenship for the most part
do so because of the way they perceive
birthright citizenship to be taken
advantage of by undocumented immigrants
and they may imagine that if you just
get rid of birthright citizenship
nothing else really changes other than
undocumented immigrants can't come to
the US and have children who become
citizens but the reality is that it's
far more complicated and once you
eliminate birthright as a path to
citizenship at all then you actually do
have to sort of think about well what
what becomes the law in terms of how one
gets citizenship and I'm already going
back and forth with a bunch of people on
Twitter and sort
spitballing ideas for a story I'll
probably do on my show next week yeah
that's really interesting that you bring
that up David because I feel like when I
first heard this story if it seemed
completely preposterous to me that he
would legally be able to do this there
would immediately be lawsuits filed by
like let's say the AG of New York
Attorney General New York for one who
would basically challenge the legality
of an executive order like that but more
interestingly is when Obama used the
power of the executive order to grant
you know asylum for dreamers the the
Republican Party flipped out and said he
was going he was abusing his power I'm
using his executive power and a lot of
people tend to agree with that like I
think that some of these personally I
think some of these executive power
should be dialed back but to support
that but to you know or to oppose that
executive order but support this
executive order kind of makes me
questions that question their
motivations about it and there's like a
secondary hypocrisy angle as well which
is just in general we all know that the
folks that are defending the legality of
news- were to at least reinterpret
constitutional amendments would I'm sure
not be open to a president doing that
when it comes to the Second Amendment
for example or others but the second is
sort of the one that comes to mind to me
the stepping back from the specifics of
birthright citizenship imagine if
President Obama had actually suggested
or even said he was considering or
drafting up using an executive order to
reinterpret any other amendment but in
particular the second they do not have
that at all so there's a level of
hypocrisy here but there's also but the
shortsightedness to it both for the
reasons that you said and also because
it's not quite so single if you
eliminate birthright to determine in a
way that even a lot of people on the
right would be pleased with how you
determine who is a citizen of the United
States
now do you know have you done any
research as to whether or not Donald
Trump himself or any of his children
have have benefited from birthright
citizenship yeah so this is actually a
story that I don't know where it started
it might have
started as a meme I don't know exactly
where I first saw it but the argument
basically was that some were making hey
listen Trump's first three kids
Eric Don jr. and Ivanka benefited from
the same birthright citizenship that
Donald Trump is trying to get rid of
because their mom Ivana Trump didn't
become a citizen until until after they
were born and I've been very very
directed ever we the left should abandon
that story 100% if your point is to show
that Trump is a hypocrite on immigration
we can do that talking about milania's
parents and chain migration we can do
that and talk about Trump's hiring of
undocumented workers to to work on real
estate projects he's associated with but
this is a really a sort of dumb story to
get behind because no matter what the
status of Ivana Trump at the time that
Eric Don junior and Ivanka were born and
of course she wasn't the citizen but she
was here legally their father was
unquestionably a u.s. born legal citizen
and it simply is is not a good story for
the left and the problem is that the way
that politics works right now as soon as
the right successfully criticizes this
argument that Eric Don jr. and and
Ivanka benefited from birthright
citizenship the left is going to be
attacked on all of their views when it
comes to this issue and there's going to
be attempt to discredit the left so it's
I don't think that that's fair but I
think that it makes sense to stay very
far away from this Trump's kids
benefited from birthright citizenship
story yeah I agree a hundred percent if
we be we then become birthers to the way
Trump had said that Obama was not a
citizen when his mother was in fact a
full naturalized citizen and he was
questioning her are Obama's citizenship
so then we just become them absolutely
and you know what if it were actually
accurate then we could say well that it
might sound like birtherism but it might
be accurate but in this case it's not
even accurate we shouldn't even be
talking about it right and it's
something that I support anyway I don't
you know I don't I you know sometimes we
point out hypocrisy 'he's
but then the the hypocrisy czar you know
we actually believe in those things that
I'm all for family reunification or
chain migration I'm all for a birthright
citizenship also is so is the
Constitution not let's not forget that
but you know I'd it's just it makes us
seem you know like we're going low when
they go low
totally agree all right well that is the
birthright citizenship argument and I
think I think you're right when I first
heard this I was like this is I don't
know if distraction is the right word
but it's an it's just another
pre-election talking point I don't want
to get wrapped up in this it's
completely illegal he'll never succeed
at it but I know there are a lot of
people out there who are worried that he
could very well with now that he's I
guess stacked the courts with
conservatives that he could very well
make it happen but I don't think he
could without a constitutional amendment
he wouldn't need two-thirds and it's a
you know all that we would have to have
a constitutional convention to even
touch that yeah and I think that there
is another interesting story that the
birthright citizenship idea relates to
and that's something I've been talking
about for a while which is the sort of
signaling that we've seen from Donald
Trump and from his administration to
extremists and white nationalists and
white supremacists and the idea of at
this point given the overtones of
repealing birthright citizenship and and
how we specifically are sort of thinking
about the migrant caravan for example
and brown people from Central and South
America this is the imagery that sort of
goes along with with the idea of
repealing birthright citizenship this is
part of the signal package I guess is
what I would call it that has really
coalesced and catalyzed the neo-nazis
and the other extremists and there's a
very long list of these signals
obviously saying there's fine people on
both sides of a neo-nazi rally and
counter protest was one of those really
really clear signs but there's a lot of
others there's you know from the
campaign we've got to shut down all
Muslim immigration until we figure out
what the hell is going on I am a
nationalist last week or the week before
the idea of we don't want people from
whole countries but what about people
from Norway coming to the United States
sending the military to the border to
stop Latino asylum seekers so there's
often these defenses of well his
son-in-law is Jewish and his grandkids
are Jewish
so therefore something but these are
really clear signals and I spoke
personally to Richard Spencer of one of
the more prominent white nationalists in
the world right now he said he reads the
signals from Trump on this issue Derek
black is a former KKK member he was
recently interviewed and he said I was
part of this group and these are signals
that my former cohort is going to hear
and think about very very favorably so
regardless of what's in Trump's mind the
more important thing is that the
extremists are hearing the signals Wow
yeah that's that's a really amazing
point David I really appreciate you
coming on today can you tell our
listeners where they can find you and
where they can watch your show yeah the
best place is just david pakman.com
we're on a couple hundred radio and TV
stations and on DirecTV and Dish and
we've got a podcast in a YouTube channel
but the the central hub for it all is my
website david pakman.com all right
thanks you guys heard it go check out
david pakman.com david really thank you
so much for coming on Malheur she wrote
thank you so much for having me